when you first learned about the
Pythagorean theorem that the sum of the
squares of the two shorter sides on a
right triangle always equals the square
of its hypotenuse I'm guessing that you
came to be pretty familiar with a few
examples like the 3 4 5 triangle or the
5 12 13 triangle and I think it's easy
to take for granted that these even
exist examples were the sum of two
perfect squares happens to be a perfect
square but keep in mind for comparison
if you were to change that exponent to
any whole number bigger than two you go
from having many integer solutions to no
solutions whatsoever
this is fair Moz famous Last Theorem now
there's a special name for any triplet
of whole numbers ABC where a squared
plus B squared equals C squared it's
called a Pythagorean triple and what
we're gonna do here is find every single
possible example and moreover we'll do
so in a way where you can visualize how
all of these triples fit together this
is an old question pretty much as old as
they come in math there are some
Babylonian clay tablets from 1800 BC
more than a millennium before Pythagoras
himself that just lists these triples
and by the way while we're talking about
the Pythagorean theorem it would be
ashamed not to share my favorite proof
for anyone who hasn't already seen this
you start off by drawing a square on
each side of the triangle and if you
take that C Square and add four copies
of the original triangle around it you
can get a big square whose side lengths
are a plus B but you can also arrange
the a square and the B Square together
with four copies of the original
triangle to get a big square whose side
lengths are a plus B what this means is
that the negative space in each of these
diagrams the area of that big square
minus four times the area of the
triangle is from one perspective clearly
a squared plus B squared but from
another perspective it's C squared
anyway back to the question of finding
whole number solutions start by
reframing the question slightly among
all of the points on the plane with
integer coordinates that is all of these
lattice points where gridlines cross
which ones are a whole number distance
away from the origin
for example the point 3 4 is a distance
5 away from the origin and the point 12
5 is a distance 13 away from the origin
the question of finding Pythagorean
triples is completely equivalent to
finding lattice points which are a whole
number distance away from the origin of
course for most points like 2 1 the
distance from the origin is not a whole
number but it is at least the square
root of a whole number in this case 2
squared plus 1 squared is 5 so that
distance that hypotenuse there is the
square root of 5 now taking what might
seem like a strange step but one which
will justify itself in just a moment
think of this as the complex plane so
that every one of these points like 2 1
here is actually an individual complex
number in this case 2 plus I what this
gives is a surprisingly simple way to
modify it to get a new point whose
distance away from the origin is
guaranteed to be a whole number just
square it algebraically when you square
a complex number expanding out this
product and matching up all of the like
terms because everything here just
involves multiplying and adding integers
each component of the result is
guaranteed to be an integer in this case
you get 3 plus 4i but you can also think
of complex multiplication more
geometrically you take this line drawn
from the origin to the number and
consider the angle it makes with the
horizontal axis as well as its length
which in this case is the square root of
5 the effect of multiplying anything by
this complex number is to rotate it by
that angle and to stretch out by a
factor equal to that length so when you
multiply the number by itself the effect
is to double that angle and importantly
to square its length since the length
started off as this
we're root of some whole number this
resulting length is guaranteed to be a
whole number in this case five here
let's try it with another example start
off with some complex number that has
integer coordinates like 3 plus 2i in
this case the distance between this
number in the origin is the square root
of 3 squared plus 2 squared which is the
square root of 13 now multiply this
complex number by itself the real part
comes out to 3 squared plus 2i squared
which is 9 minus 4 and the imaginary
part is 3 times 2 plus 2 times 3 so the
result is 5 plus 12i and the magnitude
of this new number is 13 the square of
the magnitude of their starting number 3
plus 2i so simply squaring our randomly
chosen lattice point gives us the 5 12
13 triangle there's something kind of
magical about actually watching this
work it almost feels like cheating you
can start with any randomly chosen
lattice point like 4 plus I and just by
taking its square you generate a
Pythagorean triple in this case 4 plus I
squared is 15 plus 8i which has a
distance 17 away from the origin if you
play around with this which I encourage
you to do you'll find that some of the
results are kind of boring if both the
coordinates of your starting point are
the same or if one of them is 0 then the
triple at the end is going to include a
0 for example 2 plus 2i squared gives 8i
and even though technically this is
indeed a lattice point a whole number
distance away from the origin the triple
that it corresponds to is 0 squared plus
8 squared equals 8 squared which isn't
exactly something to write home about
but for the most part this method of
squaring complex numbers is a
surprisingly simple way to generate
non-trivial Pythagorean triples and you
can even generalize it to get a nice
formula if you write the coordinates of
your initial point as U and V then when
you work out u plus VI squared the real
part is u squared minus V squared and
the imaginary part is 2 times UV
the resulting distance from the origin
is going to be u squared plus V squared
it's kind of fun to work out this
expression algebraically and see that it
does indeed check out and it's also fun
to plug in some random integers for U
and V and get out of Pythagorean triple
essentially we've created a machine
where you give it any pair of integers
and it gives you back some Pythagorean
triple a really nice way to visualize
this which will be familiar to any of
you who watch the zeta-function video is
to watch every point of Z on the plane
move over to the point Z squared so for
example the point 3 plus 2i is going to
move over to five plus 12i the point I
is going to rotate 90 degrees to its
square negative 1 the point negative 1
is going to move over to 1 and so on now
when you do this to every single point
on the plane including the grid lines
which I'll make more colorful so they're
easier to follow here's what it looks
like so the grid lines all get turned
into these parabolic arcs and every
point where these arcs intersect is a
place where lattice point landed so it
corresponds to some Pythagorean triple
that is if you draw a triangle whose
hypotenuse is the line between any one
of these points and the origin and whose
legs are parallel to the axes all three
side lengths of that triangle will be
whole numbers what I love about this is
that usually when you view Pythagorean
triples just on their own they seem
completely random and unconnected and
you'd be tempted to say there's no
pattern but here we have a lot of them
sitting together really organized just
sitting on the intersections of these
nicely spaced curves
now you might ask if this accounts for
every possible Pythagorean triple sadly
it does not for example you will never
get the point six plus a tie using this
method
even though 6 8 10 is a perfectly valid
Pythagorean triple there are simply no
integers U and V where u plus VI squared
is 6 plus 8i
likewise you will never hit 9 plus 12i
but these don't really feel like
anything new
do they since you can get each one of
them by scaling up the familiar triple 3
4 5 which is accounted for in our method
in fact for reasons that I'll explain
shortly every possible Pythagorean
triple that we miss is just some
multiple of a different triple that we
hit to give another example we missed
the point 4 plus 3i there were no
integers U and V so that u plus VI
squared is 4 plus 3i in fact you'll
never hit any points whose imaginary
component is odd however we do hit 8
plus 6i that's 3 plus I squared so even
though we miss 4 plus 3i
it's just 1/2 times a point that we do
hit and by the way you'll never have to
scale down by anything smaller than 1/2
a nice way to think about these
multiples that we miss is to take each
point that we get using this squaring
method and draw a line from the origin
through that point out to infinity
marking all of the lattice points that
this line hits will account for any
multiples of these points that we might
have missed
doing this for all possible points
you'll account for every possible
Pythagorean triple every right triangle
that you ever have seen or ever will see
that has whole number side lengths is
accounted for somewhere in this diagram
to see why will now shift to a different
view of the Pythagorean triple problem
one that involves finding points on a
unit circle that have rational
coordinates if you take the expression a
squared plus B squared equals C squared
and divide out by that C squared what
you get is a over C squared plus B over
C squared equals one this gives us some
point on the unit circle x squared plus
y squared equals one whose coordinates
are each rational numbers this is what
we call a rational point of the unit
circle and going the other way around if
you find some rational point on the unit
circle when you multiply out by a common
denominator for each of those
coordinates what you'll land on is a
point that has integer coordinates and
whose distance from the origin is also
an integer with that in mind consider
our diagram where we squared every
possible lattice point and then drew
these radial lines through each one to
account for any multiples that we might
have missed if you project all of these
points onto the unit circle each one
moving along its corresponding radial
line what you'll end up with is a whole
bunch of rational points on that circle
and keep in mind by the way I'm drawing
only finitely many of these dots and
lines but if I drew all infinitely many
lines corresponding to every possible
squared lattice point it would actually
fill every single pixel of the screen
now if our method was incomplete if we
were missing a Pythagorean triple out
there somewhere it would mean that
there's some rational point on this
circle that we never hit once we project
everything on to the circle and let me
show you why that cannot happen take any
one of those rational points and draw a
line between it and the point at
negative one when you compute the rise
over run slope of this line the rise
between the two points is rational and
the run is also rational
so the slope itself is just going to be
some rational number so if we can show
that our method of squaring complex
numbers accounts for every possible
rational slope here it's going to
guarantee that we hit every possible
rational point of the unit circle right
well let's think through our method we
start off with some point u plus VI that
has integer coordinates and this number
makes some angle off of the horizontal
which I'm going to call theta squaring
this number the resulting angle off the
horizontal is 2 times theta and of
course when you project that onto the
unit circle it's along the same radial
line so the corresponding rational point
of the unit circle also has that same
angle 2 times theta and here I'll bring
in a nice little bit of circle geometry
which is that anytime you have an angle
between two points on the circumference
of a circle and it's Center that turns
out to be exactly two times the angle
made by those same points and any other
point on the circle circumference
provided that that other point isn't
between the original two points what
this means for our situation is that the
line between negative 1 and the rational
point on the circle must make an angle
theta with the horizontal in other words
that line has the same slope as the line
between the origin and our initial
complex number u plus VI but look at the
rise over run slope of the line defined
by a choice of integers U and V the
slope is V divided by U and of course we
can choose V and U to be whatever
integers we want
and therefore we do indeed account for
every possible rational slope so there
you go the radial lines from our method
determined by all possible choices of U
and V must pass through every rational
point on this circle and that means our
method must hit every possible
Pythagorean triple
if you haven't already watched the video
about pie hiding and prime regularities
the topics there are highly related to
the ones here
[Music]
you